under pressure from global governments
to do more to help fight covet 19
the united states is sending much needed
medical supplies to india
there are a number of areas that have
are of great interest and
a great need to india at this point in
time oxygen is one of them
at india's request we are exploring
options to provide oxygen and related
supplies
we've identified u.s commercial
suppliers of remsevier that are
immediately available to help relieve
the suffering of covet 19
patients in india we've identified rapid
diagnostic testing supplies personal
protective equipment
and additional ventilators on monday u.s
president biden called
india's prime minister modi to discuss
how the two countries can work
together to protect their populations
india is experiencing one of the worst
covid19
outbreaks the world has ever seen and
oxygen supplies
are short the u.s and other developed
nations have been
under criticism for stockpiling vaccine
doses
while poor countries struggle after
weeks of hesitation
the u.s now says it will assist india
in boosting its vaccine supply 53
percent of the u.s population
has received at least one vaccine dose
of the moderna
pfizer or johnson and johnson vaccines
and appointments are now
easy to obtain but vaccines from
america's astrazeneca stockpile
have not yet been approved in the u.s
still the biden administration will now
make up to 60 million doses available
for export to countries like india
following a government review before any
astrazeneca doses are shipped
from the united states the fda will
confirm
any such doses meet its expectations for
product quality
the u.s is also sending a team of
experts from the centers for disease
control
to help india manage its crisis the u.s
actions are reciprocal india sent the
united states assistance
in the early days of the pandemic when
the u.s
was hard hit now the biden
administration
wants to return the favor medical
professionals say
the u.s move is a good start but more
must be done what's needed in the long
term is
quite clear a waiver of all intellectual
property patents
that control or that hinder district
global distribution of the coveted
vaccines
and other coveted related technologies
as india battles its covet crisis
some countries and airlines have banned
flights to and from
india but the white house says it has no
plans to ban
travelers from india to the united
states
kimberly helkin al jazeera the white
house